another thing that you did
was
take uh an honor flight and the honor
flight is a non-profit organization
great people and they provide
their their their mission is to
provide veterans with honor and closure
and so
they fly veterans to washington dc
um
to see the war memorials and your name
came up on there
and so you ended up going to washington
dc thanks to the private donations to
the op to the honor flight organization
was a great organization like i said
and you said this
when you got there
um i was ticked off because they took so
long to complete the world war ii
memorial only opening in 2004
by that time most of the men from the
war were gone and will never have the
chance to see it carlin convinced me
that i should go
in their memory so that's why i went
the irony is that the 135th infantry
which is part of the 34th division has a
shield that says to the last man
i was 15 years old the first time i saw
that
well
they are all gone except me
who would ever imagine that i would
actually be
the last man
i got that shield right here on my
jacket
uh
and then
came the battle of the bulge 75th
anniversary
and and there's a guy named mitch
mendler
oh firefighter paramedic here right here
in san diego as a matter of fact
it was him last night and he's the
president of a non-profit organization
called world memorials
and doing great work with that
and they volunteered to sponsor you to
get you out to the to the 75th
anniversary of
the battle of the bulge
and um
you say here when we went to the airport
flew down to los angeles i was met at
the gate by my sponsor group who
introduced me
to two of the men entrusted to travel
with me
colonel mike droll
of the arizona rangers and rick cochran
the executive director hispanic medal of
honor
joshua kaufman
a holocaust survivor who survived five
concentration camps was amongst the
group
when u.s troops liberated him at the age
of 16 he weighed a mere 55 pounds
his daughter interpreted it for
him in yiddish informing him that i was
going back for d-day
when she communicated that i was the
only one left in my company
he joshua kaufman
got down on his hands and knees
and kissed my feet
that choked me up
he got up
and grabbed my hand
and said
love you
and squeezed my hand
we were both crying
that's some
incredible uh you know
they mentioned closure
actually meeting an individual that had
been in the concentration camps and was
liberated by americans such as yourself
that's
amazing
that only seven years difference in my
life
i was 22
when that happened
you know i've i've read a bunch of this
book so far um tonight and
i know we've been talking for a while
but i wanted to close the book out with
this this last section that i'll read
and again if there's so much more in
this book i've only cut covered a couple
of the highlights but there's
it was hard to even select which
highlights to cover because it's all
just incredible stories
but i wanted to close with this quote
here
it says it's mind-boggling to have
someone kiss your feet and thanks for
what those soldiers did
i am not the one to be kissed
i'm representing all the guys who freed
all the concentration camp victims
it was their actions
i'm not a hero i'm here too
i'm here to tell you what i went through
all these people are gone and i'm left
alone
i can't see where i deserve the credit
for that
i'm the last one alive to represent
these guys
that gave their lives over there
so i could really relate this story
to everyone